you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme
after a summer of devastating wildfires
come the floods extreme weather batters
the pacific northwest region of north
america causing landslides and leaving
hundreds trapped
fighting deforestation the app that lets
users plant a tree for free around the
world every day
and after a watered down final agreement
and accusations of exclusivity we'll be
asking if the un climate summit is fit
for purpose
[Music]
a very good evening i'm jonathan samuels
extreme weather has been causing
devastating flooding in the pacific
northwest region of america rescue
workers are attempting to free hundreds
of people who were trapped overnight
following landslides in canada while
across the border in the u.s schools and
roads were closed and power lost to
thousands of homes
well after a summer of wildfires the
pacific northwest region is now being
hit by storms and high winds in british
columbia rescue dogs have been brought
in to look for people whose cars may
still be buried in mudslides while in
washington state major roads have been
closed and evacuations ordered as flood
waters swamp communities north of
seattle as katie barnfield now reports
this pool of mud and debris is supposed
to be a road
torrential rain in british columbia
causing such a severe landslide it
collapsed this major highway
across this part of canada and northern
usa the downpours that began on sunday
have damaged roads destroyed power lines
and forced the evacuation of an entire
town
some areas were flooded with a month's
worth of rain in one day
near the city of abbotsford helicopters
had to be sent in to rescue nearly 300
people who were trapped in their cars
overnight on a highway by falling debris
among them 50 children
in the town nearby more than 5 000
people were left without power
this weather system has been very
challenging for our teams it's had a
significant impact on some of our
infrastructure particularly in the hope
area teams are working on it they've
been there through the night throughout
the day but the weather conditions
combined with the lack of road access in
the area that's making it really
challenging
this rain has battered along the pacific
northwest including washington state in
the u.s where rescuers had to winch
people up from roofs away from the
rushing floodwater
one of them a woman clutching a baby in
her arms
with them holding it's a very small
child
these are communities that are becoming
all too familiar with extreme weather
in the summer people in british columbia
were forced from their houses because of
wildfires and blistering heat
now they've had to leave to escape
rising flood water
as firefighters built makeshift dams out
of sandbags trying to protect the homes
they left behind
local scientists are warning that these
levels of flooding are unprecedented
here they fear now that as a changing
climate brings more of this extreme
weather the infrastructure and the
people here will struggle to cope
katie barnfield sky news
well one of those local scientists is
joe boomgaard zagrodnik an agricultural
meteorologist based at washington state
university he joins us now uh joe good
to see you thanks for being with us on
the program just give us a sense of how
unusual these weather events are and
what effect they're having
yes jonathan so
this is a region that's used to getting
rainfall this time of year but the
amount and the rate in which the rain
fell was unprecedented
and this was from an atmospheric river
storm
which was part of a series of heavy
rainfall events going back to october
but this last storm the rivers were
already high and this storm just sent
them over the top to levels that we
haven't seen before in this region
joe we always have to be careful don't
we of linking extreme weather directly
to
climate change but what's your
assessment
well in this case this this scenario
that we've seen in 2021 is exactly what
climate models have been predicting for
the future
hot dry summers and wetter winters so
it's very concerning
to see these type of events happen when
it's what's been predicted by the
climate models and it's not surprising
because as the planet gets warmer the
snow levels in the mountains raise to
higher levels so when the storms hit
less of that
precipitation is captured as snow in the
mountains and more of it falls as rain
so it rushes out into the rivers and
leads to them being higher in the winter
than they would be otherwise
and of course when you have uh events
like this um the landscape but also the
infrastructure inevitably will struggle
to cope
absolutely absolutely and there's this
is a region full of trees and rivers
and bridges and when the
none of the infrastructure is designed
to handle floods of this level
and there's only a few roads going
through the mountains so as we've seen
in southern british columbia whole
cities are cut off when they're one or
two roads
are washed out and these are not just
small washouts either these are full
highways being destroyed bridges
completely destroyed so it's going to
take an incredibly long period of time
in some cases to repair this
infrastructure and then
who knows what will happen in the future
as more storms come
it may just occur again that they're
washed out multiple times
yeah it's a really uh really difficult
situation joe we must leave it there
many thanks indeed for your time
let's take a look now at some of the
day's other climate news and nicola
sturgeon has today said that the
proposed cambo north sea oil development
should not get the green light now that
is a change of position from scotland's
first minister who had previously called
for the project to be reassessed well
today she told msps that the presumption
would be that cambo could not and should
not pass any rigorous climate assessment
the decision on drilling lies with uk
authorities
it's time for the government not just to
talk tough but to act tough when it
comes to climate change so says the
shallow business and energy secretary
speaking in the commons will ed miliband
call for the uk australia trade deal to
be rewritten with new climate
commitments saying too often this
government faces both ways on climate
policy
familiar garden birds have gone into
precipitous decline in recent years
that's according to new research the
rspb says 600 million breeding birds
have been lost in the eu and uk since
1980 the house sparrow has declined 50
with a total of 247 million birds gone
from our towns and gardens
and thermal imagery from a drone will be
used for the first time on the farn
islands off the coast of northumberland
to help verify seal pup numbers at one
of the largest grey seal pup colonies in
england the atlantic grey seal is one of
the rarest seal species and is a
protected sea mammal numbers are
estimated to be around three hundred
thousand with half living in british and
irish waters
now we're losing around five million
hectares of forest every year but one
app is trying to change that tree app
lets users plant a tree for free around
the world every day and it's all powered
by adverts from sustainable brands
[Music]
tackling climate action is out of reach
for most and we identified
three main problems people don't have
time
money or know-how to take action so we
came up with trial a free mobile and
easy way to have an impact every day
directly from your phone if users choose
a location across the world where they
want to plan their tree in
watch a one minute ad from our
sustainable brand partners we'll then
fund the planting of that tree and
that's it
we need to have the world's forest today
all our sites are overseen by experts in
tropical forestry who help with our due
diligence process as well with the
monitoring of every site my advice to
anyone who wants to make an impact would
be
to start thinking about the impact that
the choices
have on the environment
then you can start your journey by
making
changes
that you're comfortable with whether it
is paying attention to labels before you
make a purchase or
attending protests
and each of these things will help raise
awareness create sustainable economies
and shape policies
do stay with us because coming up after
the break i'll be joined by
environmental campaigner and member of
the house of lords baroness worthington
and the climate justice activist days
agagi and we will be discussing whether
climate negotiations are fit for purpose
and if green technology can slow global
warming that's coming up in a couple of
minutes
[Music]
hello again welcome back to the daily
climate show here on sky news now we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day with the
environmental campaigner and member of
the house of lords baroness worthington
and also the climate justice activist
days agargy
now the reaction to cop 26 and the
glasgow climate pact has of course been
mixed and while the deal was done the
voices who say it wasn't good enough for
many and varied but with a process which
needs consensus between nearly 200
countries is there any better way we'll
be discussing that in a moment first of
all though i want to bring in that
breaking news that we've had uh in the
last hour or so that nicholas sturgeon
first minister of scotland says that the
cambo oil field should not get the green
light we know that this is a a change of
of heart um days perhaps i can get your
assessment on this first do you think
that cop 26 potentially could have
helped change nicola sturgeon's mind or
push her into this direction
yeah definitely i feel like i've seen
nicola surgeon's coverage she wasn't
just spending time in the blue zone but
she's spending time with indigenous
leaders with activists she was spending
time with the average person who's tired
of you know the fact that we've declared
a crime emergency for many years but
we're still looking to drill for oil
which is highly contradictory so i'm
really happy and quite proud the fact
that we have our politicians really
saying okay now we need to take this
seriously and we're not going to be
commissioning projects that end up
causing environmental disaster yeah
baroness wetherington we had that that
final deal of course uh at the weekend
but there are wider ramifications from
cop26 potentially
yes um the the cop process has a lot of
catalytic effects um
it passes legislation which sends a very
strong signal that the world is now
serious about tackling this cut together
all countries agreeing and
it also convenes a huge amount of people
in the side events that are there to
discuss what does the future look like
and how do we make real things happen in
the real economy so it definitely
provides a focus and uh sets momentum
off in the real economy which is
absolutely what's needed we need to move
faster and into much more ambitious
targets very quickly yeah just staying
with you baroness there was a lot of
criticism that it was a very exclusive
event but are you saying that actually a
lot of important discussion was held on
the periphery
the nature of the talks are quite
exclusive in the sense that it's a very
bureaucratic process and it's almost you
could almost say it's deliberately
opaque um the naming terminologies the
way it's run it's not accessible i i
worry that even member states actually
struggle to cover the complexity and all
of the side talks that go on that
constitute i mean 57 formal documents
were negotiated and published smaller
island states are going to struggle to
keep across all of that and so therefore
it kind of lends itself to an inside
track game and of course those people
who stand to lose from those
negotiations make sure that they're in
the room through whatever means they can
and there's been lots of reports about
how many fossil fuel lobbyists were
actually in that venue part of the
inside track which does feel quite
exclusionary at times yeah but dave
you're nodding along but there was a
huge amount of media there more than any
other cop civil society groups
indigenous communities young people etc
etc surely they all have an influence on
what's going on and help to make it more
transparent surely
i feel like they do have an influence
and even just the demands of them being
there and saying we're here we're taking
up space we're holding you into account
however there is this limitation of when
you're not actually allowed into the
room how do you make sure that you're
like picking up on the smaller details
you know like we had um the the watering
down of the final agreement and one word
was was a real change of from phase out
phase down and these are things that the
average person and the general public if
they were there allowed to observe the
process allowed to fully get involved we
will see you know like there will be
like a level of accountability that i
think governments have not had within
[ __ ] processes okay so staying with you
days uh
you've put the issues and the problems
there but what is a better solution
isn't it's not perfect but is there
anything better
yeah it's not perfect but i think there
is a lot that we can work on this
process or even rebuilding this process
in its entirety because it doesn't work
for everyone um it doesn't even work for
the president a lot sharma who very
tearingly said that he's disappointed
and he apologized for the outcome of
this talk which says a lot um
yeah but then also um
would you like to go first
he did say that didn't he he he
apologized for for the weakening of the
statement at the end but but afterwards
he did say it was historic
well this is almost a sign of how low
our expectations have been driven i'm
afraid 26 years of this have basically
meant that we're grateful for whatever
we get the success was it not blowing up
and it's not you know being a complete
catastrophe so that if that's your bar
then yes it was a success but here you
could see in his eyes that he didn't
feel that he'd done his children's
he'd done the right thing by his
children and by all those people who
were who were relying on him to get a
better deal and it's partly just the
function of how it's how it's organized
and how opaque it is and how complex it
is if it were a private sector
enterprise it would have been reviewed
streamlined and made much more
transparent and it just hasn't been and
i think that's it's no it's no one's
going to prioritize doing that but it
does need to be done for the sake of
everybody who's putting their hopes on
it yeah maybe there'll be improvements
in in 12 months time in egypt um i just
want to talk about green technology very
quickly we haven't got long um days
where do you stand on this is it the
future to to solving the climate crisis
uh the answer short answer is no
i'm not anti-technology i think there is
a space for technology in the solution
that we make to solve the climate crisis
however there needs to be awareness of
we have to solve this by the roots and
the roots is based on exploitation and
based on exploitation of people but then
also planet as well this is an issue
that stems from behavior you know and
the only way that we can really solve it
is by looking at this but then there's
also the other hand of the best carbon
sequester in the world is our earth our
earth has been doing it before humans
even existed uh this is something that i
think we have to have some like
humbleness and humility around as we
have the technology the technologies the
earth how can we help the earth heal for
you know the earth to be able to manage
its own ecosystem and we can use green
technology in the way too to get there
however we can't depend on it because a
lot of these technologies
bring up a lot of social justice issues
but then also they're extremely unproven
on the mass scale that are needed to
uphold the current structures of society
and
not enough conversations being had about
that okay and baroness worthington just
just briefly if you would
do do you agree with daisy's assessment
oh i wish i could unfortunately
nature is not on our side right you just
saw this what's happening in in north
america at the moment we've we've
basically dabbled with the global
physics and it's going to come back and
bite us i'm afraid so earth earth will
look after earth it won't necessarily
look after humans and we will need all
of our ingenuity to basically help
ourselves get back to stable climate so
i wouldn't rule anything out and i think
we have got to start building clean
technology at scale whilst at the same
time helping nature to get back to
something more normal but we're going
into a really big period of consequences
and it's going to be hard all right
we're out of time baroness worthington
days agoji thank you both very much
indeed great to get your thoughts and
that's it for tonight we'll be back up
or six